the capital of the central african
republic
under attack above the sound of russian
helicopters interrupted
by explosions and gunfire one rwandan
u.n peacekeeper was killed
dozens of rebel fighters died in combat
one of the rebels is captured alive but
security forces save him from a mob who
want him dead
later he's paraded on state tv by the
country's security minister
luke these are foreign fighters this one
doesn't even speak french or the local
language
he is now in our hands thanks to the
cooperation
of the people of the central african
republic on tuesday prime minister
fermat negabada with the unn russian
escort visited the neighboring town of
bhuali to boost
the troops morale
dozens of government forces are
deserting the front line too scared to
fight against what appears to be a
well-equipped and well-organized rebel
force
using guerrilla warfare tactics the
rebels have taken control of more than
two-thirds of the country
the enemy is composed of rebels from all
over the central african republic
coming from the borders of cameroon chad
sudan the fulani in the interior of the
country
the anti-balika and the gabayan majority
military
including jean-darm and police they are
all in this coalition
their size is about 9 000 men their
intention is to overthrow the government
in place and force the population into
submission in three days
the offensive comes days before the
constitutional court is to confirm
president arkham stuart's victory in
december's presidential election
the government accuses former president
francois bouzize of fermenting unrest
russian fighters are patrolling the
capital securing strategic positions
including the presidential palace
much to the relief of people living in
bengi
as long as the russians are here i feel
safe their presence with the u.n forces
is reassuring
but even still the future remains
uncertain
at the request of france the former
colonial power in the central african
republic
the u.n security council is discussing
the presence of russian fighters
in a country where it had a stronghold
french troops left in 2016 after
soldiers were accused of rape and sexual
violence against young girls
in their absence russian fighters are
now more visible
in a country on the brink of civil war
nicholas hawk al jazeera